winter is coming so take the black and
defend the wall the Watchers on the wall
have a feeling this is probably going to
be one of my shorter episode reviews
because whereas your typical Game of
Thrones episode jumps around location
several different places lots going on
this entire episode is about one thing
the assault on Castle black by the
wildlings I don't consider that a
spoiler to say that because we've been
building to this since last season we
all knew it was coming so it's finally
here does it deliver well yeah it's no
small thing to have basically what is a
battle that lasts almost a solid hour
that's really difficult to pull off
because generally your audience is gonna
be fatigued by the end of this thing
just going ok enough enough enough it's
really well paced and there are a fair
number of damn kind of moments and
they're well spaced across the episode
and it also takes a few minutes to slow
down in a couple places and give us some
nice character beats we get some nice
stuff with Sam Jon Snow gives us some
good stuff even though Sir Alastair the
guy who's running the Night Watch who I
complain about before he even gets some
good moments and also the episode just
makes really good use of members of the
Nights Watch whose faces we've seen
before and seen with the wildlings for
that matter we don't really know these
characters we don't know their names but
we've been seeing them and the camera is
really sure to sort of linger on these
people and these faces that we've seen
before to give a little more way to
what's going on and our way I'm not sure
there's too much more I can say about it
without sort of going beat for being
that gets it a little bit too much into
specific spoilers I mean not really like
plot spoilers but they're in moments I
would rather you go and get to see for
yourself as well constructed as this
episode is it does have a couple of
things working against it the first is
honestly that might as well have just
called the Blackwater - they are really
chasing and trying to recapture the
strength and the power of the 9th
episode of season 2 Blackwater even
going so far as to get Neil Marshall to
come and direct the thing again now that
in and I myself it's not a criticism
Neil Marshall perfect for this sort of
stuff but between bringing him back
having it been the 9th episode again and
having it just such an overall similar
feel it just it feels like chasing past
glory as far as world
Longo's again it's really well executed
but it can't quite have the same impact
in much the same way that say in the
Lord of the Rings trilogy the the battle
at ministereth is awesome and it's
amazing it's I think but it can't quite
have the impact that the Battle of
Helm's Deep had even though that was a
smaller fight it just at the time that
it happened was so much bigger than
everything else that had gone on it was
just wow it blew your way then when they
sort of take that next thing to scale it
up a bit it's still very cool but it
can't have that same initial impact and
we kind of got the same thing going on
here
the other thing this episode I was
working against and is the fact that
honestly the previous episode kind of
had a better climax in terms of the
overall arc of the season just the stuff
that went on last episode really just
built to a stronger more personal and
more emotional climax as well as being
viscerally exciting whereas this one has
all of that but it just can't quite pull
off the same weight so as good as it is
coming off of the previous episode it
feels like just a slight tick down as
opposed to a continued upward trend in
that way I feel a little bad for this
episode I feel like it's not gonna get
the recognition it sort of deserves if
you look at it in isolation because in
the overall scope of the season we hit
our peak last episode and that's not the
fault of this episode this episode is
good it's really good but last episode
just it packed more punch I think that's
really kind of all there is to say oh I
do want to single out and give praise to
Neil Marshall there is this one shot
it's this 360-degree long panning shot
just of all this carnage going on and
just that it that the shot just keeps
continuing our oath was actually shot
continuous or if there were hidden cuts
in there but it looks like one shot and
it's just epic intense and it just keeps
going whoa it's an amazing sequence so
let me ask you this and this question
isn't really tied specifically to this
episode but I'm just wondering is there
one character in this show that if they
killed this character off you're gonna
be like that's it I check out because
obviously this is show where where we
know anyone can die so is there one
character that if they actually do kill
them off are you gonna go that's it if
you've got a character like that
down on the comments and let's talk
about it until next time this council is
adjourned